in 1986 the late John Hughes gave film
audiences one of his most beloved teen
dramedies and teen Heroes filled with
memorable scenes Zippy one-liners and a
Motley cast of characters Ferris
Bueller's Day Off is a film that not
only stands the test of time but helped
Define a genre but watch this classic
again as an adult and you realize that
more than a few parts of the movie are
actually pretty cartoonish and require a
serious suspension of disbelief here are
just a few examples unbelievable toys
from his totally boss stereo to his
killer IBM computer and Beyond Ferris
has a bedroom that would make him the
Envy of any 80s teen hi Ferris how's
your body
oh my God you're dying then there's that
awesome synthesizer he uses to make
convincing fart and vomit sound effects
while rallying the troops at school it's
an emu emulator too the creme de La
Creme of synths used by 80s bands like
Depeche Mode it would have set ferris's
parents back about eight grand an insane
price tag considering there's no
evidence Ferris even knows how to really
play it or any other instrument or that
his parents are quite that well off
never add one lesson
hey
wacky wardrobe Ferris changes his outfit
and absurd nine times before Cameron
even picks him up in the morning pulling
looks out of The Ether Like Bugs Bunny
all before 10 AM ferris's assorted looks
range from PJs to pool attire from luau
gear to hip Jazz Cat various states of
undress coming to and from the shower
plus his blue suit that he plans to wear
to trick Mr Rooney into thinking he's
Sloane's dad time travel early in the
movie Ferris and Cameron make their
phony phone call to Ed Rooney from
ferris's house and disagree about how to
handle picking up Sloan at school to
ferris's dismay Cameron AS Sloan's Dad
blurts off that Mr Rooney should have
Sloan outside the school in 10 minutes
by herself this leads to a series of
events that would suspiciously take
longer than 10 minutes Paris and Cameron
argue over the details Ferris delivers
an emotional apology and the two are
Chums again they then travel to
Cameron's house where Ferris convinces
Cameron to borrow Cameron's dad's
vintage Ferrari they secure the vehicle
and travel all the way to Shermer High
some somehow arriving only a minute or
so after Mr Rooney and Sloan emerge
identity crisis the biggest mystery
about Sloane Peterson is how seamlessly
she goes from utter Terror that ferris's
Dad might spot her in the taxi line at
the restaurant to nonchalance about
making kissy faces to Mr Bueller later
from the back seat of another taxi cab
sure she has those Ray-Ban sunglasses on
as a brilliant disguise but even
perpetually oblivious Mr Bueller must
recognize his son's super serious
girlfriend right considering Ferris
proposed to Sloan back at the stock
exchange things might get pretty awkward
at the wedding
mysterious gifts aside from a quick
visit from Mrs Bueller to check in on an
ailing Ferris and ferris's sister
Genie's time at home when she kicks Mr
Rooney in the face and huddles in her
bedroom to call the police the Bueller
home is mostly empty for the day while
Ferris enjoys his time off yet when
everyone comes home at 6 PM the hallways
are filled to the rafters with the
balloon and flower delivery sent by the
entire town to wish ferris's speedy
recovery so who accepted all those
deliveries it couldn't have been genie
in fact we see her slam the door in the
singing telegram nurse's face and it
likely wasn't Mr Rooney because the one
vase of flowers we saw him pick up ended
up on the head of the family's
Rottweiler despairs have a robot Butler
among his many fabulous toys the late
bus there is Bueller's Day Off is loaded
with brilliant moments and immensely
quotable lines but the fun doesn't stop
when the credits roll you've gotta love
seeing the disheveled and broken Mr
Rooney accepting a warm gummy bear from
his bespectical bus seat mate set to the
unforgettably catchy strains of yellows
oh yeah
I bet you never smelled a real school
bus before but when you watch it again
as an adult you realize there's
something peculiar about that school bus
filled with teens pulling up to Mr
Rooney and asking him if he needs a ride
we know it's now long past six o'clock
P.M and those kids should have been home
hours ago who are these kids is the
driver lost considering everything else
he managed to pull off sticking Rooney
on this bizarre bus just might be
ferris's handiwork
it's good for him it teaches him to deal
with his fear
[Music]
Jumanji Welcome to the Jungle turned out
far better than anyone had any right to
expect what initially sounded soulless
and cynical ended up being a massively
successful well-received family-friendly
Thrill Ride for kids and adults alike
starring Dwayne Johnson Kevin Hart Jack
Black and Karen Gillen the movie
effectively built on the 1995 story
about a magical board game with a video
game-based body swap comedy sequel
Welcome to the Jungle made a lot out of
a wacky premise but that doesn't mean it
was perfect many of its quirks won't be
picked up by younger viewers but the
adults in the room probably noticed them
here are some of the things only
grown-ups will notice in Jumanji Welcome
to the Jungle
what console is that Jumanji opens in
1996 introducing viewers to a teenage
boy named Alex in a sleeveless Metallica
tee whose bedroom is covered in pop
culture posters from the era nothing
says 1996 teenager like his quick
dismissal of the Jumanji board game in
favor of his trusty PlayStation
controller we see he's playing Twisted
Metal a game that was released for the
PlayStation in November 1995 but when we
paused to Marvel at all the authentic
90s stuff in his room we get a good look
at the console itself spoiler alert
that's no PlayStation it doesn't even
remotely resemble a PlayStation from the
looks of things its closest twin is the
Atari 2600 a wood paneled console that
was already 20 years old in the mid 90s
and of course since you've noticed it
once you're not going to be able to
ignore that all the controllers go from
PlayStation to vaguely nintendo-esque
when the kids pull the game out at the
school fittingly enough they can't make
heads or tails of this odd Contraption
either there's
a cool Nintendo or something
I don't think so
I don't recognize it
have your cheesecake
it seems to be a common belief that just
acknowledging overdone cliched tropes is
enough to subvert them in movies or
shows but that's not really always the
case Jumanji uses Martha as a mouthpiece
to criticize the unnecessarily skimpy
outfit worn by her Avatar Ruby
roundhouse but as good a sentiment as
this might be the film is making this
commentary on how women are designed in
video games well it's simultaneously
benefits from having a young actress in
a skimpy outfit fortunately the movie is
brimming with charm and doesn't rely too
heavily on sexy shots of a woman's body
to keep people watching in fact she adds
bits of her male companions outfits to
her own in order to feel a bit more
comfortable as she Journeys Through the
Jungle kicking bad guy but with her
dance fighting techniques but the
marketing for the movie has no such
subtlety making this a noticeable
instance of Jumanji wanting to have its
cake and eat it too
perish the thought at the midpoint in
the film when the teens have been set
upon by corrupt researcher Russell Van
Pelt and there's no obvious way to move
forward the missing teenager Alex shows
up in the Avatar of Jefferson seaplane
McDonough he leads Our Heroes through a
hallway full of authentically video
gamey traps to his little Hideaway set
apart from the main Jumanji playing area
he's been holed up there for who knows
how long keeping his head down and
trying to hold on to his last life he
explains to the new kids that the little
Bungalow where he lives drinking
delicious Margaritas is not a structure
of his own making instead it once
belonged to a man named Alan Parrish
Alan parish is of course Robin Williams
character from the original Jumanji not
only is the reference a lovely tip of
the hat to Alan's character it also
gives fans of the original movie a
glimpse at how Allen was living during
his years away
Alex's amazing slang
he's pretty fly she's a bomb I'm just
saying I'm sure they'd like to get jiggy
with her Alex's tortured 90s slang is
out of place in the jungle and also this
Century but his lame-o vocabulary helps
the four kids realize that the Alex
they've found inside the game is Alex
reek the boy who's been missing and
stuck in Jumanji for 20 years it's not a
bad idea to use outdated slang to tip
off the characters that Alex is from
another era but there are a few problems
here one is that Will Smith's getting
jiggy with it came out in 1997 not 1996
plus exactly zero people have ever
actually used the phrase getting jiggy
in conversation ever ask your parents
also if they were going to go there with
that style of slang they probably should
have gone with a different
characterization for Alex instead of a
Metallica tee and a grungy hairstyle he
probably should have been wearing a
cross colors tank top and some radical
prints the walls of his bedroom should
have been covered in TLC and Michael
Jordan posters now that's 90s instead
his lingo comes off as forced everyone
knows mid 90s metal heads didn't say
anything was the bomb then again
really knows what they say sometimes
the empty fridge well Kevin Hart does
good work as fridge's Avatar the fridge
himself has no real Arc and learns no
valuable life lessons in the movie
things start off promising we learned
that fridge asked Spencer to do his
homework as a favor which turns out to
be a bad idea Spencer may be a nerd but
he's not necessarily a good student and
the bogus paper he provides for fridge
is easily snipped out by his teacher as
a result fridge gets kicked off the
football team later when fridge and
Spencer's tension comes to a head on a
cliff in Jumanji they get into a shoving
match costing Spencer one of his lives
but by working together through the rest
of the adventure they gain a mutual
respect for one another still at the end
of the movie the problems that led to
that Cliff confrontation are still there
the boys haven't hashed out their
personal conflict fridge doesn't
apologize for using Spencer to do his
homework nor for insulting and
intimidating him in Jumanji they don't
team up in the real world to get fridge
reinstated to the football team there's
no shot of fridge working hard on his
own homework or doing anything to wrap
up the problems that got him into
tension in the first place all that's
changed about him at the end of his
Bogus Journey was Spencer Bethany and
Martha is that he seems nicer and
vaguely content the movie doesn't want
you to notice it but his academic and
athletic future is still severely
compromised by the movie's end
compare him to the other characters
Bethany finally begins to take an
interest in the world outside herself
Spencer gets the nerve to take a chance
and kiss Martha and Martha gets over her
shy nervousness enough to kiss him back
fridge just spent all afternoon playing
video games but all of his problems are
still there that's kind of how real life
works too
the Alex paradox
Jumanji is a family movie so a happy
ending is pretty much par for the course
but let's put on our thinking caps for a
second the implications of Alex
returning to the moment of his
disappearance after being trapped inside
the game for 20 years should probably be
more severe than the movie lets on no
seriously let's talk about this if a
butterfly flapping its wings in one
location can have a dramatic ripple
effect on everything else in the world
than a human teenager going missing
would fundamentally change the fabric of
at least Brantford New Hampshire Alex's
unexplained disappearance from this
small town was a major cultural
Touchstone for everyone who lived there
it's mentioned multiple times by
different characters at the start of the
film and it's the sort of event that
would have all kinds of small effects on
people's relationships and Behavior
parents probably have his disappearance
in the back of their minds while they're
raising their kids old man freak who is
once vigorous and full of life has his
Destiny dramatically Changed by the
anguish for mysteriously losing his Sun
The Disappearance leads other people in
town to be more cautious over the years
that follow the ending should have been
more like Back to the Future with the
tiniest changes in the past having major
effects in the years that followed but
nope that never happened even after the
timeline where Spencer fridge Martha and
Bethany were living in gets winked out
of existence and replaced by this new
world where Alex never went missing
everything outside of Alex's family ends
up being exactly the same beyond the
confines of his household it appears
that Alex's absence from the world meant
just about nothing that's insane right
at no point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought look okay fine sure we realize
this is a movie about a magical video
game but that still just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense okay
Thundercats ranks among the best
cartoons of the 80s alongside the likes
of Masters of the Universe and
Transformers you may not have noticed at
the time but Thundercats has some truly
unusual touches that read very
differently to adult eyes
[Applause]
bit of a sweeping epic and it all begins
with an off-forgotten origin story The
Thundercats have to leave their doomed
home planet of thundera and at the time
Lionel is just a young boy they're also
mostly underdressed by the way but that
changes quickly because of a long
journey ahead of them the cats have to
spend time in suspended animation on the
way to their new home when they arrive
on third Earth young Lionel finds that
his body has grown into that of a
muscular adult man but his mind is the
same why I'm grown even though the
original team includes three actual
adults Lionel is still the team leader
because he's a hereditary Lord of The
Thundercats early on Lion knows
immaturity and naivety is a story point
but before long that aspect mostly Falls
by the wayside there are plenty of
moments when Lionel's Behavior makes
more sense when you remember that he's
just an enormous kid but it's almost
never made explicit after that first
episode the fine figure of a Thundercat
new grown up to be Lionel and so
handsome too as sandera falls apart
during the show's Premiere the central
Thundercats escaped the destruction
under the leadership of their Wise Old
leader Jagger Jagger doesn't live to see
their new home on third Earth but he
frequently returns as a shimmering blue
Ghost no specific explanation for the
destruction of thundera is given in that
first episode it's only much later in
the third season episode Thunder curbs
that we learn the reason for the entire
planet falling apart and it's all
Jagger's fault come join me for a
history lesson
years earlier when Jagger was a much
younger man cat he had defeated a
muesan's leader named ratilla he had
carried a double-bladed magical weapon
the sword of plunder which is basically
the evil equivalent to the ThunderCats
own Sword of Omens upon defeating
ratilla Jagger threw the sword of
plunder into a volcanic Canyon in order
to destroy it however he underestimated
the sword's evil magic and the sword of
plunder Works its way to the core of
thundera splitting the planet apart
surprisingly little is made of the fact
that the wise advisor who has guided the
ThunderCats all this time actually made
the mistake that cost them everything
Thundercats largely takes place on a
planet called third Earth but that can't
possibly be our earth right it just
looks too weird we live on first Earth
or as we call it Earth the third one
must be out in space somewhere however
if you pay attention the show makes
clear that third is a matter of time not
space this is Earth in its third age
when humans are no longer the dominant
species and many any of the planets
inhabitants are alien colonists and
refugees from across the cosmos the fact
is made especially clear in the episode
Excalibur when Merlin makes a guest
appearance and reveals that the King
Arthur stories took place on the same
planet with a Thundercats now live
Merlin isn't the only ancient Immortal
who survived from first Earth to third
the show's main villain mumra falls into
the same category with his glowing red
eyes deathly gray power and twisted face
mumrah is terrifying as 80s cartoon
villains go which is all the more reason
that it's not entirely obvious that he's
the only human being in the main cast of
Thundercats at least mumrah used to be a
human being he's an ancient Egyptian
sorcerer who was granted immortality by
his Gods who he calls the ancient
spirits of evil Egyptian history is
avoided on Thundercats but it's hard to
miss that mumra is a mummy who lives in
a pyramid and the ancient spirits of
evil have human bodies and animal heads
just like many gods of Egyptian
mythology mum Ra's name is a portmanteau
of mummy and the Egyptian Sun God Ra so
while the ThunderCats arrived from
thundera and the mutants come from the
planet's plunder and even the burbles
arrived on third Earth in a spaceship
mumura has been here all along of all
the ThunderCats characters he's the one
with whom we share DNA and he's not
completely wrong about being upset at
the invasion of his Planet early on the
powers of the ThunderCats mystical Sword
of Omens seems pretty clear it magically
extends from dagger length into a full
sword it casts a big red cat signal into
the sky to summon the other Thundercats
it shoots energy beams and it allows
Lionel to see across great distances
sight Beyond sight
foreign
as the series goes on however the Sword
of Omens has whatever Powers it needs to
have to resolve a particular plot it can
project both Fire and Ice at various
moments can project solid objects like
walls and bridges it flies and even
allows its Bearer to fly whenever that's
convenient it even prevents a
Thundercats home planet from exploding
for a second time a magical sword with
many uses is fine but as an adult viewer
it's pretty clear that the writers would
just give the Sword of Omens a new power
anytime they wrote themselves into a
corner
think I'm funny do you care for most of
the series snaf is just another in a
long line of annoying little squeaky
voice characters who don't fit in their
shows a lineage stretching from
Scrappy-Doo to orko to Screech but snuff
once had a very specific job acting as
Lionel's Nanny just let the boy come
down with a fever or the PIP or
something and who gets the blame poor
old snap that's
that Malino was a kid snuff was employed
to watch over him and keep him safe once
he has an adult body Lion Hotel snuff he
doesn't need that anymore even though
he's become even more prone to getting
into trouble than ever before and
Snarf's entire existence has pretty much
rendered pointless snaf is a chronic
Warrior which makes him suited to
babysitting but when he doesn't have
that job anymore the same quality is
what makes him incredibly annoying
[Music]
with 2017's Thor Ragnarok director Taiko
watiti gave us something completely
different from the previous two Thor
films showing us places and characters
unlike anything else in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the Fantastic visuals
and Rapid Fire jokes were enough to
Dazzle movie fans of any age but while
kids might be satisfied with spectacle
once older viewers really start thinking
about the movie there are more questions
than answers especially once you factor
in the events of Avengers Infinity War
here's a spoiler-filled look at some
Thor Ragnarok details that only adults
notice
Odin stinks at hiding things the key
villain for most of Ragnarok is hella
the goddess of death who also happens to
be Thor and Loki's older sister and the
oldest child of Odin hella it turns out
was banished by Odin hidden away in a
secret prison until his death abruptly
frees her suddenly the secret Ain't So
secret which is actually a recurring
problem for Odin throughout the Thor
franchise as the all father is
apparently really bad at hiding things
in the first film it was the secret of
Loki's Frost giant birth in the second
it turns out there was a secret portal
out of Asgard now here comes a daughter
that he apparently never told his sons
about and in all three cases once the
secret got out people got killed if Odin
were a little better at hiding these
things Asgard might still exist today
where is Sif both of Thor's leading
ladies from the previous films are
suddenly and mysteriously missing in
Thor Ragnarok Jane Foster's absence is
explained with a single throwaway line
saying she and Thor broke up that's a
pretty casual dismissal for a star as
big as Natalie Portman but it's nothing
compared to what Jaime Alexander's lady
Sif gets which is in fact literally
nothing aside from an actress playing
her in the drama Loki stages
commemorating his own death Sif isn't
even mentioned in Ragnarok in the real
world Alexander apparently had a
scheduling conflict but in Ragnarok she
just vanishes and nobody really seems to
give a crap Marvel later piled on even
more with Avengers Infinity War
directors Joe and Anthony Russo
revealing she died off screen in
Infinity War seriously guys who is on Dr
Strange's watch list though the film
spends less time on Earth than either
previous Thor Adventure Ragnarok does
depict Thor and Loki's affected
encounter with Dr Strange who traps Loki
in a pocket Dimension while he has a
chat with Thor about why they've come to
earth I keep a watch list of individuals
and beings from other Realms that may be
a threat to this world your adoptive
brother Loki is one of those beings it's
a fun scene but it makes you wonder who
else is on that watch list is Doctor
Strange the Marvel equivalent of the TSA
we have a feeling we haven't seen the
last of this mysterious watch list of
his
Thor God of nothing in addition to
extreme strength durability and a
lifespan much longer than that of a
human Thor is the God of Thunder which
is a key plot point in Ragnarok are you
sore the god of hammers hmm
that hammer was to help you control your
power to focus it
it's not your source of strength so if
his body is naturally gifted with the
power to channel lightning why is he so
vulnerable to shocks he gets shocked by
a net thrown on him by scavengers when
he first arrives on zakar and then is
repeatedly Zapped by the neck implant
placed on him by Valkyrie after she
captures him maybe those don't run on
normal electricity or something but it's
weird to see him get shocked in one
scene and then pull a lightning storm
out of the sky in another
Valkyrie has a drinking problem the last
time we meet Valkyrie she falls off her
ship after taking a big drink the moment
is played for Laughs as are other
moments involving Valkyrie and alcohol
but as the story plays out we find she
is using alcohol to block traumatic
memories of her friends being
slaughtered by hella though her
addiction is mostly played for Laughs
when viewed as a whole Ragnarok actually
presents a tragic view of a woman trying
to drink herself into Oblivion
where is Asgard exactly in the first
Thor film The bifrost is the only way to
get to and from Asgard which is why it's
such a tragedy when it's destroyed in
the second movie though we learned our
actually secret portals that sometimes
allow travel to and from Asgard as well
okay fine in Ragnarok though all bets
are off as people seem to be able to
come and go at will simply flying
spaceships to and from Asgard apparently
the rules for traveling to Asgard work
however the plot needs them to at any
given moment as seemingly anyone can
just drive there if they want so road
trip anyone
Infinity what now
speaking of all those as Guardians on
that spaceship Avengers Infinity war
begins shortly after Ragnarok left off
with the Asgardian Refugee ship
destroyed by Thanos in the Carnage we
see the loss of numerous asgardians but
we don't know anything about what
happened to Valkyrie or Korg in a q a at
an Iowa high school of all places though
Infinity War co-director Joe Russo
revealed that Valkyrie survived along
with half the asgardians so where are
they well one clue might be hiding in
plain sight at the end of Ragnarok as
the grand Masters pleasure Cruise vessel
battered but still recognizable can be
seen parked on top of the larger Refugee
ship it's not big enough to hold
everyone but Valkyrie could certainly
fit and maybe even have room to bring
Korg with her here's hoping
with sci-fi adventure and a cast of
cosmic Misfits that includes a talking
raccoon and his best friend a tree it's
no surprise that Marvel's Guardians of
the Galaxy was a big hit for kids when
it hit theaters all the adults who saw
it however might have noticed a few
other things that flew right over the
younger viewers heads
destination Earth
even though he was taken from Earth as a
child and raised Among The Outlaws known
as the ravagers one of the key
components of Peter Quill's character is
his intense connection to his Homeworld
it's exemplified through the awesome mix
cassette tape given to him by his mother
before she died which he listens to
non-stop to form the film soundtrack
when we see Peter as an adult it's been
26 years since he was abducted into
space by the ravagers and he's still
holding on to the mixtape his backpack a
troll doll and the few other mementos he
has of his old home he's also a capable
pilot who knows his way around the
Galaxy and even has his own spaceship
named after the decidedly earth-based
celebrity Alyssa Milano so he definitely
tried to go back to Earth at some point
right maybe not recently since he seems
to have settled into the life of a
space-faring Outlaw but it's hard to
imagine a universe in which Star-Lord
didn't run away from the ravagers and
head back home at the first chance he
got even if it was just to see if the
Jackson 5 ever put out another song
unfortunately that's not a story we've
ever seen unless he spent a few years
under cover in Pawnee Indiana there's
only one man for the job Bert Macklin
tale of the tape
Peter's trusty Walkman and the Mixtape
contained within it are more than just a
playlist it's his main attachment to the
memory of his mother and it became the
essential Hallmark of the film too it's
embedded in the very fabric of the
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise so
much so that when he has to escape from
space prison Peter risks his life and
his freedom just to get the tape back
and it also represents a genuine miracle
in audio preservation technology as
anyone who is actually around in the 80s
knows cassette tapes aren't exactly the
most durable format especially if you're
playing them over and over for say 26
years and yet Peter's mixtape and the
Walkman he uses to play it are in
perfect working condition after being
bounced around the universe for a
quarter of a century and that's not the
only tape Tech Peter has either Sony has
a repair Tech in nowhere or Peter just
happened to run into the only member of
the Nova Corps who could hook him up
with a tape deck pulled straight out of
the dashboard of a custom van
0g
when the team is taken to the Kiln
prison it's up to Rocket to come up with
a way to get out and what he comes up
with actually ends up working pretty
well the Escape Plan hinges on the team
getting up into the guard Tower turning
off the artificial gravity in the prison
and then simply flying away it's a good
idea but it also involves at least one
very large chunk of luck for some reason
when the artificial gravity goes off the
Kiln guards many of whom had previously
been holding riot shields and rocket
launchers just start madly flailing
around as they float not only do they
never recover as the Guardians make
their escape they also drop their
weapons obviously suddenly losing
gravity would have an element of
surprise but if you're going to build a
super secure prison in the depths of
space you'd think training your guards
to fight in zero g would be one of the
first things you'd do the second thing
telling them not to drop their guns at
the first sign of trouble
the ravager diet
Peter is abducted from Earth as a Boy by
the ravagers a group of Outlaws with
their own code and system of command who
were hired by Peter's still mysterious
father to bring him back yondu the
leader of this particular faction of
ravagers decides to keep Peter and raise
him like a murderous outer space Mary
Poppins
rather than dosing his medicine with a
spoonful of sugar though yondu keeps
young Peter in line by reminding him
that he saved him more than once from
being eaten by his fellow ravagers they
seem pretty eager to find out what
creatures from this distant planet
called Earth taste like when I picked
you up on Tara these boys of mine wanted
to eat yeah they never tasted any Taran
before I nothing so our ravagers space
cannibals or do they just consider human
beings to be livestock they're made up
of all manner of alien species so if
they were that willing to drop a clearly
cinchy and Peter Quill onto their plates
at lunchtime have they also eaten
members of each other species too that
could make for some pretty awkward
conversation around the table but the
movie never bothers to answer this
question even though we're hungry for
answers love and the single alien
Star-Lord definitely fits into the
lovable scoundrel category and
apparently that includes all definitions
of lovable he apparently has a tendency
toward meaningless flings with all
manner of alien species he has a woman
whose name he's forgotten in his ship
when we first meet him he hits on Gamora
when he sees her and later he tells Drax
various stories about alien women who've
attacked him after he romanced his way
out of and into plenty of trouble if
you've ever watched Star Trek and seen
Captain Kirk's attitude towards the
prime directive when it comes to Green
women you already know this isn't
exactly a new element for sci-fi still
we have to ask do all humanoid looking
aliens have compatible reproductive
organs the only elaboration we get from
Peter is a story about flirting with a
woman who had tentacles and needles for
teeth he says he only spent time with
her in a quest for information but what
would have happened if he'd taken that
interaction to the next level maybe
we're better off not knowing lazy lazy
Thanos after Avengers Infinity War we
all know Thanos is a super villain who
could be not just a mastermind but a
punishing and Relentless Force before
infinity War though his major abilities
seem less built around fist fighting
gods and more about delegating tasks to
lesser villains this is especially
evident in Guardians of the Galaxy as he
did in the Avengers Thanos sends someone
else Ronan the Accuser to obtain an
infinity stone for him rather than doing
anything himself he spends all of his
time Seated on a floating throne in
space hurling threats and giving orders
but never actually showing the audience
why he's so dangerous it definitely
works in the context of the larger MCU
but if you were to watch this film on
its own you'd essentially just be taking
everyone at their word that Thanos is a
bad dude here he's basically a guy who
tells everyone else to go do something
for him while he kicks back and gets
irritated when they fail no wonder Ronin
decided to strike out on his own when he
realized he had an infinity stone in his
possession
mint condition
when the Guardians realize they need to
get rid of the orb before it falls into
the wrong hands gamora's plan is to sell
it to the collector in ancient and
Powerful being who well collects things
if they give it to him she reasons they
can both no longer be responsible for it
and get paid The Collector is happy to
oblige but while the group is in his
home he notices something else he'd like
to buy Groot
must allow me to pay you now this is
what I make on your carcass at the
moment of your death of course while
it's certainly nice of him to pay up
front and wait for group to live a full
life the film also makes it pretty clear
that the collector has no such Scruples
about other specimens in his collection
numerous living seemingly sentient
things are visible in his display cases
including Marvel's own Cosmo the space
dog and Howard the Duck here's hoping
they were offered a better deal than the
one Groot was going to get you know how
to whistle don't you of all the
interesting space technology on display
in Guardians of the Galaxy there's
nothing more intriguing than yondu's
yaka Arrow lifted straight from the
comic page the incredible sharp and fast
weapon is controlled through whistling
and a technological fin on yondu's head
and it's powerful enough to slaughter a
whole group of enemies with a simple
Melody it's a neat piece of gear and
while it's certainly very effective in
its current form it's hard to watch the
yaka arrow in action and wonder why
yondu isn't thinking bigger sure the
arrow is elegant but what about a rocket
launcher that works the same way or a
drone or a whole ship perhaps it
requires more mental energy and control
than yondu's whistle can summon or maybe
it's just limited by being in range of
the whistle sound meaning that he
couldn't fly the arrow through the
silent depths of space but it seems like
they might be shooting pretty low even
though it's remarkably effective
foreign
because of its grown-up Characters
themes and complex mythology 1999's The
Mummy provides plenty of moments that
adults will be thinking about long after
the kids in the room have moved on to
the next thing
in the film's prologue the Magi Warrior
Artist Bay explains that anaksu namun
was the pharaoh's mistress and it was
forbidden for any other man to touch her
to make this point anaksu namun wore
very little clothes and was instead
covered in an elaborate body paint
design that ran over most of her body
when her secret lover the high priest
emotep touched her in a moment of
passion he smeared the paint it's that
smudge that reveals her betrayal to the
Pharaoh the smudged body paint is a
clever shorthand that lets the audience
in on the moment without over explaining
it but any adult who's ever put on
makeup body paint or even Halloween
costume has to wonder why that's the
look The Pharaoh settled on it certainly
let him know that someone touched his
mistress but it seems like anaksu namun
could have just as easily smeared the
paint by bumping into a wall or laying
down for a nap plus waking up and
applying all of that paint every day
must have been the worst morning routine
ever no wonder a naksu namun went
looking for another man
after the murder of the Pharaoh and
anaksu namun's death imotep launched a
plan to resurrect his beloved that
involved a forbidden ritual at
hamanoptra the city of the dead imotep
dead the Gold's anger by going deep into
the city where he took the Black Book of
the Dead from its holy resting place
unfortunately the pharaoh's bodyguards
followed imotep captured him and
subjected him to the hamdai a curse so
cruel that the Egyptians had never
performed it before after being
mummified alive and entombed in a
sarcophagus filled with scarab beetles
cursed to remain the undead for all of
eternity imatep's body was buried in
hamanoptra then a group of Warriors
called the Magi began their
millennia-long effort to watch over the
city they knew that if the high priest
ever returned he would become an
all-powerful being that could destroy
the world it begs the question why did
the ancient Egyptians need to use that
particular curse if it had such
potentially devastating consequences why
not just mummify him alive like they did
with the rest of his priests it makes
sense that emotep be punished for his
crimes but this insane curse feels like
an unnecessary risk Evelyn Carnahan and
her brother Jonathan are the descendants
of great explorers and their Adventure
begins when Jonathan unknowingly steals
the map to hamanoptra from Explorer Rick
O'Connell while investigating it Evie's
boss Burns a part of the map this
convinces Evie that they need Rick's
guidance if they ever hope to find the
lost city she decides to Spring Rick
from prison with a little bit of bribery
aimed at the warden if you cut him down
we will give you
10 50 20 4 30 25 deal
once released the small band of
explorers head off in a race against a
group of treasure Hunters who also want
to discover the hidden Egyptian City of
the Dead the journey is more than a bit
bumpy after the Riverboat catches fire
and sinks the gang takes the camels to
make the rest of the trip eventually
they find themselves on a desert plane
looking at the Sunrise it's then that
Rick informs the group that they have to
wait for the sun to hit an exact point
in the sky before the location of
hamanopra is revealed to them the
treasure Hunters have caught up to them
at this point and as the city is
revealed it becomes a race to see which
group reaches their destination first
the problem here is that Rick shouldn't
need the sun to show him the way to
hamanoptra he's been there before after
all if he knew where to stand for the
sun to reveal the city there's a good
chance he could have navigated the rest
of the way simply by memory it would
have removed the need for a race but
then again the race is a pretty great
set piece for the movie over the course
of the Mummy the film lays out an
elaborate mythology for the fabled city
of hamanoptra though many believe its
own a myth various Scholars have done
research on it and the film establishes
clearly that the city is a very real and
very haunted place in fact the Magi have
spent Millennia guarding it and trying
to keep it secret despite the fact that
not everyone in the movie believes in
hamanobra a lot of people still seem to
have a fairly easy time getting to it a
massive battle erupts amongst its ruins
near the beginning of the movie and two
Expeditions travel back to its location
years later Evie talks frequently about
its layout and Rick notes that Tales of
hominopra are so pervasive that his
military unit defied orders to march to
Egypt from Libya to look for it so while
the Magi are rather reactive once people
make it to hamanoptra maybe they should
start branching out into more proactive
efforts to keep Legends of the city a
little more tamped down it might make
their job easier
though it draws inspiration from
historical Concepts like mummies and the
Egyptian concept of the afterlife and it
also mentions historical figures like
seti the first The Mummy is firmly based
in the world of fiction it's a big fun
fantasy horror Adventure which allows it
to take a lot of Liberties even with
Biblical history one of the warnings
given by the Magi about the horrible
fate that would befall the world should
immotep rise from the dead is that he
could bring the return of the plagues to
Egypt and sure enough as soon as he's
back things like swarms of locusts and
Fountains of Blood start to plague the
world once more despite emotep
referencing the language of the slaves
when he hears Benny speaking Hebrew
there aren't any biblical references in
the movie yet the plagues in question
are specifically drawn from the book of
Exodus so why does emotep get to use the
plagues that God devised to torment the
Egyptians it's probably because these
days the plagues are more associated
with Egypt in general as opposed to the
specific story of Moses freeing his
people from the oppression of the
Pharaoh the plot of The Mummy requires
some very specific events to take place
for it to make sense some of these
events rely on ancient Egyptian rituals
that many of the characters must
discover and then perform correctly in
fact the climax of the movie involves
Evie Rick and Jonathan battling the
all-powerful emotep and relies on the
recital of spells from a pair of
mystical books The Book of the Dead
contains spells needed to resurrect
people and the Book of almond Rock
contains the spells that allow someone
to command the dead or render the undead
mortal once again both of these ancient
tomes are presented as extremely
dangerous in the wrong hands and they
even require a special key that unlocks
the books and allows them to be opened
unfortunately locking the books doesn't
seem to prevent some characters from
using them near the end of the film
Jonathan gets hold of the book of Aman
ra and manages to command a group of
mummy Soldiers by reading an inscription
on the cover apparently you don't need
to understand what you're reading to
make the Spells work which increases the
danger posed by them line with the fact
that some of the Spells are written
right on the cover of the books it gives
the impression that the Egyptians who
wrote These volumes probably should have
taken a little more care before
publishing or at the very least devised
a more foolproof security system
the Mandalorian is a hit with all ages
but chances are that only the adults in
the audience will notice these nods
references and details from references
to Classic works of Foreign Cinema to
Star Wars trivia hear other things only
adults notice in the Mandalorian
although it takes place in a galaxy far
far away the Star Wars franchise can be
viewed as a study of spaghetti westerns
and Samurai movies George Lucas has
openly acknowledged the direct influence
films like Akira Kurosawa the Hidden
Fortress and Sergio Leones The Man With
No Name Trilogy had on his space cowboy
stories likewise Mandalorian Creator
John Favreau has also cited the two
genres and directors as major sources of
inspiration for his show he's even been
quoted as saying dinjarin is a
deconstructed version of Clint
Eastwood's iconic Leone character
another major Mando inspiration is the
film series Lone Wolf and Cub sometimes
known as Shogun Assassin in the U.S this
classic story follows a disgrace
shogun's executioner forced onto the
path of an assassin who must take his
young son with him he pushes a little
one around in a tricked out baby Card
sound familiar
although the Mandalorian pulls heavily
from the somber tones of spaghetti
westerns and Samurai films it has plenty
of laugh out loud moments too
particularly ones poking fun at the Star
Wars franchise itself these sarcastic
memes are all too familiar to mature
fans who have been dismantling or the
irregularities and quirks of their
beloved franchise for years one of the
more memorable of these tongue-in-cheek
scenes occurs in chapter 12 The Siege
while Mundo grief kaga Kara Dune and the
unnamed mithril are infiltrating an old
Imperial base on Navarro the crew
encourages the myth roll to walk out on
a precarious ledge over lava to access
the Machinery controls to which he
replies that there's no guard rail a
stark lack of safety ratings on Empire
ships is something Star Wars fans have
been joking about since the first film
was released in 1977 and was most
notably mocked in a Star Wars Parody
episode of Family Guy Blue Harvest
so anyway I says forget the dental plan
forget sick leave I just want a railing
you know one railing right here another
hilarious moment of self-deprecation in
the Mandalorian happens during the cold
open of chapter 8 which shows two
Stormtroopers missing repeatedly while
firing at a piece of scrap within close
range the scenes playing on the age-old
Trope of the notoriously bad Blaster aim
for a guy who never shows his face din
jarin is a huge chick magnet younger
viewers may not notice but mature
audiences will pick up on the fact that
excluding Cara Dune the few
non-mandalorian females he's crossed
paths with have either been instantly
attracted to him or had some sort of
romantic history with him in chapter 4
The Sanctuary didn't crosses passed with
a young Widow named omera who seems to
want the warrior to settle down with her
bad boy Mando also seems to have broken
the heart of Xi'an a knife throwing
twilek he works with in chapter 6 The
Prisoner she threatens to use her blades
against him for whatever Shenanigans he
pulled on her in the past
adults will likely appreciate the Shia
irony of seeing comedian Bill Burr cast
in a Star Wars related role longtime
fans of his podcasts know that the
snarky Bostonian has long riffed on the
franchise as he never forged a personal
connection with the original trilogy
when it was released in his youth burst
set up controversy within the Star Wars
fandom for remarks he made in 2015
declaring that what he did finally watch
the original trilogy in his mid-20s he
wasn't impressed I read a quote that you
had this is a while back I think you
caught Star Wars a Cheesy self-help book
put in outer space with outer space yeah
to be fair Bill makes fun of everyone
and everything equally even his beloved
sports team still it may seem curious
that John Favreau would cast it about
Star Wars hater in the Mandalorian as it
turns out Burke claims Favreau chose him
precisely for this reason stating he
thought it would be funny
Gina carano's background makes her the
ideal candidate for playing Cara Dune
the most recent addition to Star Wars
collection of fierce brunette heroines
before she started acting Carano was a
Muay Thai Fighter who launched her
career as one of the first mainstream
female mixed martial artists competing
back when the sport started blowing up
in the 2000s after earning an MMA record
of seven wins one loss and zero draws
Carano transitioned into acting in 2008
with the role of Natasha volkova in EA's
real-time strategy video game command
and Conquer Red Alert 3 her ability to
perform her own stunts and make action
look realistic on screen has kept her
busy with various action roles since
yet another influence bound to be missed
by younger viewers can be seen in
chapter 9 the Marshall in which Mando
travels to the Frontier Town of mos
pelgo on Tatooine seeking out other
mandalorians to Aid him on his quest
Mando gets sidetracked helping the
martial destroy a local sand dwelling
monster that has been plaguing his town
known as a greater crate Dragon crate
dragons are initially mentioned in Star
Wars A New Hope when Obi-Wan Kenobi
scares off a group of sand people
attacking Luke Skywalker by imitating
its Eerie Hull a crate dragon's bleach
skeleton can also be glimpsed poking out
of the Tatooine sand behind C-3PO early
in the film however this terrifying
BEAST's appearance on the Mandalorian
references the 1990 sci-fi horror cult
classic Tremors in that movie Giant
worm-like creatures called craboids lurk
underground waiting to strike their next
victim when they least expect it
while innocent young minds go no further
than admiring grogu's core powers and
cuteness Factor adult Minds can't help
but wonder where grogu came from if he's
not a clone as has been implied in the
show thus far then he was spontaneously
created like Anakin Skywalker or he was
made the old-fashioned way so far the
only other creatures encountered like
grogu and Star Wars have been Yoda and
the adult could grogu's existence
explain the latter's sudden
disappearance from the Jedi High Council
that all remains fan theory for now but
regardless of who sigh of the being
formerly known as baby Yoda the Twisted
adult mind can't help but wonder how
such creatures would accomplish
procreation awkward it would be yes a
pleasant image it is not
foreign
kids with very strange and mature tastes
they likely missed a quick Mandalorian
reference to the classic comedy office
space the film parodies all the negative
aspects of toiling away at the dreaded
9-5 Cube farm from Horrible Bosses and
wasting away in traffic anyone who has
ever worked a less than desirable job
can relate to this movie Office Space
also makes fun of a necessary corporate
bureaucracy and paperwork symbolized by
the dreaded TPS reports in the film it's
just we're putting new cover [ __ ] on all
the TPS reports before they go out now
so if you could go ahead and try to
remember to do that from now on that'd
be great these reports are seem to have
made their way into the Star Wars
Universe because Mayfield mentions them
in chapter 15 The Believer it's such a
quick line and easy to miss come on
let's go fill out those TPS reports so
we can go recharge the power coil and
you thought the empire was evil before
chapter 15 is loaded with Quentin
Tarantino references Mayfield and Mando
find themselves in a dangerous situation
while posing as Empire Personnel when
officer Valen Hess insists they join him
for a drink they risk exposing
themselves while swapping small talk but
they can't break Rank by refusing hess's
offer so they agree the suspenseful
scene is reminiscent of the hair
raisingly intense bar scene in
Inglorious Bastards both feature
characters infiltrating enemy cultures
while attempting to blend in as Natives
and to both situations soon explode into
a violent catastrophe Mando and may Feld
Frolic at the Empire Bar might also
remind an adult viewer of a scene from
Django Unchained when Dr Schultz gives
Calvin candy a bullet rather than a
requested handshake just like Schultz
Mayfield is so overcome with loathing he
can't help but pull the trigger and thus
puts his companion in grave danger also
like candy Hess has a thick southern
accent under Sinister yet lackadaisical
demeanor
a towering villain requires an actor of
serious skill luckily the mandalorians
violin Hess is played by a highly
accomplished actor adults will likely
recognize Richard breaks succeeds in
making his character absolutely hateful
but then as grown-ups know he has a lot
of experience in that department breaks
started his acting career in 1993 with a
small part as a reporter and a British
comedy Drama TV series Jeeves and
Worcester since then Breakers performed
in dozens of projects and at least 30
Films spanning or genres one of his more
memorable roles to date has also been
one of his most brief he was cast as a
night King in the fourth and fifth
seasons of Game of Thrones
like many Disney movies Avengers end
game threads the needle between age
groups trying to offer a solid story
that youngsters and adults can
appreciate but also adding enough mom
and pop jokes to keep mom and pop
engaged Avengers end game had plenty of
things that went right over kids heads
spoilers ahead after the five-year time
Jump early in the film we see Captain
America leading a grief counseling group
meant to help people move on after
thanos's snap with half the living
creatures in the universe gone there are
a lot of issues left unresolved all
their surviving Avengers are struggling
to move on after the weight of a
crushing genocidal loss that's beyond
alien to most kids adults on the other
hand are more likely to key into what
are obviously some largely unhealthy
coping mechanisms for The Avengers loss
of them all Tony is the closest to
moving on in a healthy way but he's done
so by moving as far into the country as
he can so as to never engage with the
wreckage of his biggest heartbreak he's
deep in denial to the point where he
kicks The Avengers out when they try to
convince him there's a chance to make
things right it wouldn't be an
exaggeration to say that both Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers end game are
built on Father issues you've got the
ultimate abusive big dad and Thanos who
tells everyone he meets that his
genocidal Warpath is all for the good of
the people he's killing that he's
actually being the good guy by doing the
bad thing for the right reasons then
you've got Tony Stark who struggles with
being a father figure for Peter Parker
and For Whom the latter's death weighs
heavily enough in end game to lead Tony
to undertake a mission through time to
bring Spider-Man back then there's Thor
who often struggles under the weight of
his own father's expectations basically
a lot of the Avengers are working
through their dad issues which is
crystallized and a long moment of Tony
talking to his father Howard Stark while
on a mission through time in the 1970s
Tony manages to have a pretty in-depth
heart to heart with his old man Even
though Howard has no idea that he's
actually talking to his son Tony finally
gets to work through some of his
feelings and admit that Howard was a
pretty good dad on Underneath It All
it's the kind of perspective that you're
not likely to get unless you're well on
your way to becoming a dad yourself what
is and always will be my greatest
creation
is you
when Thor and rocket go back to Asgard
to get the reality Stone the God of
Thunder pretty immediately gets
sidetracked when he sees his mother
friega Thor remembers that the day
they're visiting Asgard is the same day
his mother dies in the past which brings
up some understandably complicated
emotions for him Friga finds him however
and they're able to have one last loaded
conversation about family the future and
the burden of expectations it's the kind
of perfect last conversation that many
adults wish they could have had with
their parents after they passed that
level of melancholic fantasy isn't
common for most kids thankfully and the
opportunity for Thor to have one last
chat with his doomed mother likely put
more than a few adults in the audience
to tears real people don't have the
ability to go back in time and get
closure with their parents but plenty
have dreamed of the chance while Captain
America has been leading therapy
sessions and Natasha has been leading
superhero teams Thor has been leading
new Asgard at least in terms of alcohol
consumption the massive amount out of
alcohol Thor's been drinking has given
the God of Thunder a bit of a beer gut
which leads to a handful of fat jokes
throughout the rest of the movie he's
clearly dealing with depression and
grief and it's led him into a
destructive lifestyle that's radically
changed his body kids may or may not
recognize that Thor's newly rotund
figure is a product of beer drinking and
they certainly aren't going to Clue Into
Thor's decision to look for a way out of
the emptiness of his life at the bottom
of a bottle when it comes to time
traveling movies bangs almost never make
sense for very long most of the time
these movies just kind of ask you to
accept the basic concept and ignore
anything weird that happens later end
game however spends a lot of time
calling out various misconceptions about
how time travel works in the MCU movies
get involved when Rhodey and Scott Lang
list off some of their time travel
favorites Back to the Future Hot Tub
Time Machine Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure Star Trek Quantum Leap time
cop and the Terminator most kids aren't
going to have seen more than a couple of
movies on the list and they rattle them
off so quickly that even a adults might
have trouble keeping up still even if
you were quick enough to recognize the
films and remember each one's specific
rules regarding time travel it doesn't
matter Hulk pretty quickly shuts Roadie
and Scott down immediately by telling
them that they're all wrong after Scott
finally escapes the quantum realm thanks
to a helpful rat he has to alert a
security guard to let him in his Quantum
realm doohickeys out of the storage
space they're being held in that
security guard is played by none other
than Ken Jung who's previously worked
with the Russo Brothers on the series
community
and a one a two a chain chang four The
Cameo alone might be enough to mention
here but there's one more detail in that
scene that's just for adults the
security guard is reading J.G Ballard's
the terminal Beach a collection of
Science Fiction short stories one of the
most famous stories in the terminal
Beach is called end game it doesn't bear
many similarities to the film but the
shared title is certainly no coincidence
if you thought there was something
Vaguely Familiar about Thor's hair beard
and sunglasses you weren't the only one
Tony Stark noticed too for a good chunk
of the film it seems like Chris
Hemsworth's Thor is taking style lessons
from Jeff Bridges the dude of Big
Lebowski Fame I'm the dude so that's
what you call me you know the R-rated
cult classic from 1998 isn't a movie
that most kids are going to be familiar
with but end game isn't content just to
leave it as a visual gag when Stark
calls Thor Lebowski in passing it takes
the quick gag into meta territory
Bridges played both the dude and also
Obadiah stain way back in Iron Man
staying was Tony's business partner and
eventually his super villainous rival as
Iron Monger that Tony is the one to call
Thor out on his resemblance to one of
bridges's less villainous roles is icing
on a cake that's just for the adults in
the audience
just because it's a serious mission
doesn't mean there's not a bit of room
for levity Ant-Man and Iron Man
certainly take that to heart when they
Journey back to 2012 along with Captain
America in order to get some of the
Infinity Stones both Tony and Scott take
a moment to critique the past version of
Captain America's hindquarters and his
Avengers era geta ultimately Scott
proclaims it to be America's ass which
is hard to argue with later in the film
when President cap is fighting past cap
he takes a moment after the fight to
admit that he really does have America's
best but it's clear in just about every
scene but that rearward looking dialogue
is likely to fly right over kids heads
albeit with some giggling that one of
their favorite Heroes just set a mild
cuss word meanwhile the adults in the
audience are likely to feel a bit called
out for staring
the rise of Skywalker is filled with
plot twists and references that only
older fans will get as well as some
disturbing ideas that only mature
viewers will notice children will enjoy
the Skywalker sagas finale just fine but
will they pick up on these plot points
we think not spoilers ahead
so let's talk about the rise of
Skywalker's big secret Rey is
Palpatine's granddaughter surprise and
maybe not Abrams has been hinting that
he undid the last Jedi's nobody twist
for a while now and leaks about Rey's
true Heritage have been circulating on
the internet for months but at Palpatine
as a granddaughter that means he has a
kid if you're old enough to know the
story of the birds and the bees you know
that means old wrinkly yellow-eyed
Palpatine played a little ding dong ping
pong with some lucky lady he's fully
operational if you catch our drift
unfortunately the rise of Skywalker
doesn't reveal the identity of
Palpatine's lover or children leaving
the comics and novels to explain those
Mysteries that's too bad because we'd
love to meet the woman who got seduced
by those shapeless black robes we bet
she has some interesting stories to tell
it took 11 films but there's finally a
canonical same-sex couple on screen in a
Star Wars movie no it's not the sequel
trilogy's most dynamic couple Finn and
Poe Dameron it's Commander dossy one of
the top ranking resistance officers and
her wife a resistance fighter named Roby
Tice who lack lips while the resistance
is celebrating the defeat of Palpatine
kids probably won't even notice the
moment which is over almost as soon as
it begins but adults will certainly
realize what the inclusion of a same-sex
couple in a Star Wars feature film means
over the past four decades Star Wars has
been remarkably conservative when it
comes to depicting relationships but
most adults will also realize that it's
a very small step simply showing two
women kissing isn't real representation
dossy isn't a real character in the film
we don't know her hopes dreams
motivations or fears heck we barely even
know what she sounds like Darcy was a
good start but Disney and lucasfilm
still have a long way to go
even if children are aware of Carrie
Fisher's passing they're probably not
going to give too much thought to how
Leia returns for the rise of Skywalker
there's too much else going on for those
of us who grew up with Princess Leia
however it's almost impossible not to
think about Fisher's death in 2016 every
time her most famous creation shows up
on screen as such adults are probably
going to notice all the tricks that JJ
Abrams and the rise of Skywalker crew
used to give Leia the send-off she
deserves as promised Abrams used
outtakes from the force awakens and The
Last Jedi and Leia's scenes not a
digital Recreation you can tell Leia's
lines are noticeably vague it's up to
her scene Partners to deliver the
specifics given the situation it
actually works pretty well Leia is the
heart of this movie and it's wonderful
to get a chance to say goodbye but the
sleight of hand is something most adults
will definitely notice
C-3PO gets the rise of Skywalker's best
lines but one of the movie's funniest
moments doesn't have any words at all it
comes at the very end of the movie as
everyone celebrates Poe Dameron sees his
old friend zory Bliss they lock eyes
Pogue and zory an inviting tilt of his
head sorry shakes him off Poe looks
disappointed the audience person to
laughter the subtext should go right
over kids heads but every adult in the
theater will realize that Poe is asking
zory if she wanted to get busy they'll
also know that zory completely shut him
down now well there's no harm in trying
look poe just defeated an entire fleet
of Star Destroyers he won the war
emotions are Riding High who can blame
him for calling up an ex to blow off
some steam
Ray Finn and pose Quest takes them to
the planet Persona where a festival is
taking place the party C-3PO explains is
thrown by the pasana natives the Aki Aki
and is held once every 42 years if
you're one of the lucky youngins who
grew up in an age when new Star Wars
movies have been a thing that number
won't mean anything to you if you've
been following the Skywalker Saga since
the very beginning you should know
immediately how Abrams and his co-writer
Chris tario landed on 42. Star Wars
Episode 4 a new poke came out in 1977.
Star Wars Episode 9 the rise of
Skywalker came out in 2019. guess how
many years apart that is
42.
maybe that's a clue for the future too
Disney says that its next Star Wars film
will debut in 2022. so you might as well
go ahead and set aside some time in 2064
now you'll certainly want to see how the
next Saga ends
the rise of Skywalker reveals that
before he joined the resistance Poe
Dameron used to run spice the way the
other characters reacted it's not a good
thing but it doesn't sound so bad who
doesn't add a pinch of cumin or paprika
to their dishes while they cook even in
space boots should taste good
hmm
except that's not the kind of spice
they're talking about just from the
language used as well as the precedent
set by Frank Herbert's Dune mature
members of the audience who don't
already know will quickly figure out
that in Star Wars spice is basically
slang for drugs he who controls the
spice controls the universe Poe Dameron
wasn't helping people season their meals
he was profiting off of other people's
addictions in the Star Wars Universe the
drug trade is just as vicious and
exploitative as it is in real life it's
not a good thing for someone like Poe to
be involved in of course in his prime
the renowned scoundrel Han Solo was
known to smuggle spice too no wonder
Leia likes him
kids love Scooby-Doo but there's a lot
of questionable aspects to the mystery
series but they might not catch until
after they've grown up he is the most
suspect stuff in Scooby-Doo shows that
only grown-ups pick up on
Scooby-Doo is so familiar that we all
tend to overlook at Central conceit one
of the main characters is a talking dog
but even more unbelievable than a Great
Dane who speaks and experiences human
emotions while the reactions are the
people around him I was saving this for
an emergency this is an emergency that's
the last hamburger Shaggy Fred Velma
Daphne and the various criminals a burst
are never impressed or freaked out by
scooby Scooby's human-like intelligence
and ability to speak should probably
make him a Marvel of nature science or
both but everybody Converses with Scooby
like it's the most normal thing in the
world
talking dog aside the cast of most
Scooby-Doo shows has led by the same
four humans of Mystery Incorporated Fred
Jones Daphne Blake Velma Dinkley and
Norville Shaggy Rogers together this
unlikely foursome travels to land in
their psychedelic van solving Mysteries
and debunking supernatural phenomena
that much is obvious but what isn't
clear is just how old they're all
supposed to be it'd have to be at least
16 to drive that sweet van and making
them teens would put them closer to the
show's Target demographic of children
plus civilians love to call them
meddling kids but it also seems like
they must be at least in their 20s since
teenagers wouldn't likely be found
living unsupervised on the open road and
speaking of the open road why are they
out on the road in the first place are
they homeless or possibly fleeing
something ghastly since the show was
originally produced in the late 60s and
early 70s one possibility could have
even been that Fred or Shaggy was
dodging the Vietnam draft and Daphne and
Velma just went along for the ride
good work school
kids may not pick up on the candle after
in each episode of Scooby-Doo but adults
can't help but wonder what business a
laugh track has on an animated
children's show True the laughter may
help remind young viewers that despite
its spooky situations Scooby-Doo is
supposed to be a light-hearted comedy
but a laugh track suggests that the show
was filmed in front of a live studio
audience which is impossible with the
cartoon like Scooby-Doo then again in
keeping with the spirit of the show
maybe those laughs are coming from
ghosts or are part of an evil plot hatch
by a corrupt amusement park owner while
kids may not pick up on some of the
show's less than subtle Stoner Vibes
among certain adult viewers Scooby-Doo
cartoons have long been beloved due to
Shaggy and Scooby's Telltale habits a
children's cartoon may not ever
explicitly state that his characters are
marijuana enthusiasts but the clues in
Scooby-Doo are Bountiful enough for the
Mystery Machine doesn't exactly need a
legalizer bumper sticker to make the
theme clear for example Shaggy and
Scooby can sometimes be seen emerging
from a big smoke cloud additionally the
pair is obsessed with food particularly
junk food it's almost as though these
two giggling Slackers want a firmware's
bell bottom pans and sports uncomped
hair always have the munchies which begs
the question if Shaggy smokes marijuana
with his dog isn't that animal abuse
goal number one for Shaggy and Scooby
has always been to eat as much as
possible and the two frequently care
more about finding their next meal than
doing their job of solving Mysteries but
while the duo is constantly eating
adults May notice that they actually
have a few dietary restrictions in some
of Scooby-Doo's more recent episodes
Shaggy often expresses is desire for
veggie sandwiches and other substitutes
for typical fast food Staples this is no
accident Shaggy moved away from meat in
2002 at the request of the guy who
provided his voice legendary disc jockey
Casey Kasem was a noted vegan and he
wanted to use his platform as Shaggy to
educate kids about the benefits of a
vegetarian diet
we changed management last week now
we're organic vegan
every episode of Scooby-Doo seems to
follow a formula the gang drives through
the night comes across a potentially
haunted location and gets down to
business looking for Clues then although
it's never a good idea to go off alone
in a dangerous place the four humans
inevitably decide to split up and if
things weren't already scary enough Fred
their self-appointed leader always has
to go and make things even creepier
whenever the pairings are made Fred
sawanu decides he will go off with whom
invariably he pairs himself with Daphne
the subject of his intense romantic
interests no matter what case they're
investigating Fred never fails to get
Daphne alone with him in darkened rooms
under the guise of doing their jobs what
a creep
adding a young energetic character to
revitalize a show that's getting a
little long in the tooth is a well-known
television tradition and one that almost
always fails miserably on Scooby-Doo
this sort of cynical attempt to boost
ratings resulted in one of the most
universally loathed characters in
cartoon history Scrappy-Doo a pint-sized
version of Scooby Scrappy was clearly
supposed to be cute but wound up just
being annoying although he's meant to
serve as a contrast to Scooby's laid
back Freddy cat energy Scrappy do comes
across as aggressive and perpetually
angling for a fist fight not only is he
a character nobody wanted or asked for
but adults may be concerned about
Scrappy's excessively violent tendencies
and wonder whether he might even be a
bit disturbed
have you ever noticed that Scooby-Doo
seems to take place in the bizarre world
of meteorological anomalies where it's
always dark and seemingly cold while
kids may not notice that we rarely see
the sunshine on the Mystery Incorporated
crew adults May question the persistent
night time of the extended Scooby-Doo
Universe Additionally the Nia
omnipresent fog suggests the perpetually
cool climate as does Fred's heavy
looking shirt and velma's choice to
always wear a cozy orange turtleneck
sweater but Shaggy is always in a
t-shirt which begs the question just
what temperature is it in this world
when it began Scooby-Doo was a silly
formulated cartoon about a dog on some
young people encountering ghosts which
always turned out to be Shady business
owners trying to scare people off their
property but starting in the 70s to mix
things up writers and animators had the
mystery solvers interact with various
guest stars whose real world
counterparts could be living dead or
even fictional for example in one
installment Scooby and his friends meets
Laurel and Hardy the famous comedy duo
those are actual people who lived but
both died long before the episode aired
on other occasions the Scooby-Doo crew
met Sonny and Cher the nuts Josie and
the Pussycats and Batman the presence of
some of those guest stars would suggest
that the Scooby characters are real
since they interacted with actual living
humans but if some of those humans were
dead does that mean the mystery machine
is unstuck from time and is Batman real
too fiction and real life are
confusingly blurred making the reality
of Scooby-Doo a little tough to Define
for young Scooby-Doo viewers it may not
be obvious that the episodes tend to
follow similar trajectories which always
lead to a version of the same ending
what was thought to be a haunted
building turns out to not be so haunted
after all ghosts goblins Spooks and
specters that scared the Mystery
Incorporated crew so badly are revealed
to be some combination of projections
Shadows sound effects and master bad
guys in other words Scooby-Doo
constantly reiterates that all of that
spooky stuff isn't real and that there
is always a logical explanation for any
Supernatural occurrence most of the time
the mystery the character solve is
revealed to be the plot of a developer
or landowner hoping to scare people off
their land because greed is usually the
only real scary thing in the Scooby-Doo
Universe yet every time the Mystery
Incorporated team heads out on a new job
they seem to completely forget this
important fact and the dozens of normal
jerks they've unmasked in the past every
episode features a gang overreacting to
what they think is a ghost or Monster
leading to Shaggy screaming let's get
out of here then Shaggy and Scooby and
sometimes in entire gang inevitably flee
and Terror either they have terrible
memories or their fear of ghosts are so
severe that they ignore all logic which
kind of makes you wonder why they win
their supernatural detective business to
begin with based on what happens during
every single mystery they've encountered
one of them were to walk right up to the
monster or ghost the first time they see
them and tear off that mask but that
thought never seems to occur to them but
of course if the characters actually
learned from their previous cases
there'd be no more show
apart from mowing lawns and selling
lemonade most kids don't worry too much
about putting cash in their pocket
grown-ups though are concerned with
earning a living to provide Necessities
like food shelter and clothing so
naturally adults watching Scooby-Doo
might have some questions about how
business is conducted at Mystery
Incorporated at first glance Mystery
Incorporated seems to be a legitimate
operation with the Incorporated part of
the name indicating that the detective
firm is registered with an oversight
agency and pays taxes but despite the
official sounding name adult viewers May
Wonder exactly how this company is able
to operate although money rarely changes
hands business still appears to be
booming at least enough for the firm to
afford a company car or in this case a
groovy van one wonders what sort of
waves the four humans earn and whether
or not Mystery Incorporated offers
Health vision and dental benefits
in classic episodes of Scooby-Doo the
dedicated detectives of Mystery
Incorporated navigate through the many
back roads and Country highways of
America forever in search of their next
sleuthing gig but if you look closely
that straightforward premise may have
some dark undertones in the world of
Scooby-Doo all the buildings seem to be
falling apart and the land is started
with closed amusement parks and long
abandoned ghost towns all of this
coupled with Shaggy sheer relief
whenever he comes across food suggests
that these young entrepreneurs are
trying to get by in a world that has
taken a pretty significant turn for the
worse perhaps a severe economic
depression left the country in shambles
awesome kind of natural or man-made
catastrophe prompted people to flee all
those small towns a show may be for kids
but all the signs seem to indicate that
Scooby-Doo might be a glimpse at life in
a post-apocalyptic and Nightmare anyone
who's caused a few episodes of
Scooby-Doo over the past 50 years
probably recalls the words to its bouncy
memorable theme song the theme song
seems to imply that Scooby-Doo spends
most of the show being hard to locate
and that the Mystery Incorporated team
is constantly searching for him so that
they can get to work but that's not
actually what the show is about at all
Scooby-Doo never disappears during the
episode and he and Shaggy are never
apart for long sure Scooby may run away
from scary stuff but Shaggy is always
with him making the song suggestion that
Scooby is constantly missing a real
mystery
Disney's Sky High is a Charming
superhero movie about growing up getting
through high school and saving the world
if you only ever watched it as a kid
however you're missing a lot of the
movie's best puns details and Dynamics
these are the parts of Sky High only the
grown-ups get
Sky High's protagonist Will Stronghold
has multiple Tenacious D in The Pick of
Destiny posters on his wall this R rated
2006 Stoner comedy focuses on a pair of
slackers on a quest to become the
greatest band of all time not exactly
the kind of thing the kids watching the
PG rated Sky High would tend to notice
but that's not the only interesting bit
of memorabilia in Will's room he also
has a poster of the Aquabats a
celebrated real world superhero rock
band known best for their costumes and
sense of fun not only does that put
Will's tastes in line with the coolest
nerds of the 90s it works in Universe
perhaps the Aquabats are actually
superheroes in the world of Sky High
Beyond this will has sketches a lot of
space-themed window stickers and posters
and even a guitar leaning up against the
wall behind a weight training bench at a
normal high school he probably would
have actually been cool with or without
superpowers Layla's pacifist attitude is
a common theme throughout the movie she
even refuses to show off her plant-based
Powers because doing so violates her
principles she thinks a person's power
should only be used when the situation
demands it does she live up to this code
well not really Layla uses her abilities
to give her Crush an apple and make a
flower at a restaurant table Wilt not
exactly high stakes moments of life and
death so perhaps it's not surprising
that she seems to be violating her own
principles when she's seen sporting a
leather bag not many kids notice Layla's
bag or the other inconsistencies in her
philosophy but adults will catch on
quickly of course adults also understand
that the teenage years are the age at
which one learns that principles are
complicated Layla's figuring out her own
values and how best to carry them out
still someone should probably tell this
girl about the wide world of fake
leather goods there's principal Powers
look familiar kids look at her and see
any other grown-up but adults will
likely notice something familiar in her
face that's because she's played by the
one and only Linda Carter who portrayed
the titular heroine of the 1970s Wonder
Woman TV series this reference was
actually meant to be more overt but
copyright got in the way originally the
plan was for principal powers to sport a
pair of gold bracelets referencing
Wonder Woman's legendary bullet
deflection accessories unfortunately
Warner Brothers the owners of the Wonder
Woman copyright objected thus the
bracelets were banished but as sky-high
fans know this doesn't mean there were
no nods to Carter's Amazonian history in
the film
I'm not Wonder Woman you know
while kids likely we'll just consider
this a throwaway line every grown-up in
the audience will get a chuckle out of
the reference additionally nurse specs
is played by Cloris Leachman who played
Wonder Woman's mother in the same show
like any school Sky High is a learning
institution full of teens forming their
first political opinions the Nuance of
this Dynamic most likely escapes kids
but adults catch every single line take
this Exchange in response to the
students learning about how they'll be
sorted into the school hierarchy power
placement sounds fascist Layla might be
a little dramatic but she's not wrong
this school runs on the kids on the hero
track being separated from those
destined for hero support otherwise
known as sidekick status speaking of
Sidekicks a writing joke revolves around
the preferred terminology for Less
powered individuals which any adult can
recognize as reminiscent of many real
world debates I believe the preferred
term is hero support for now then
there's the scene where Josie and Steve
try to work out their schedules and
Josie mentions a particularly amusing
upcoming appointment about a government
agency many people find particularly
evil
when are we briefing the president on
supervillain infiltration of the IRS
there is perhaps no joke that flies
higher over kids heads than this one but
their parents get a good chuckle out of
it figuring out once taxes can certainly
feel like being ensnared in some super
villain scheme Sky High is jam-packed
with puns and allusions to idioms and
media that few kids will notice at most
kids might catch the oxymoron and Warren
Peace's name but not know the classic
work of literature by Leo Tolstoy it is
based on his name also refers to the
conflicting nature of his parentage his
mother is a superhero and his father is
a villain it's punny as well as
thematically resonant adults may also
catch a Sly reference to another
well-known Kurt Russell role after
taking a distress call the commander
dramatically informs jet stream that
there is trouble downtown then repeats
himself
big trouble
downtown this is a clever nod to 1986's
Big Trouble in Little China which
starred Russell as a tough trucker
battling an ancient sorcerer meanwhile
while Gwen Grayson is the main villain
of Sky High her name contains references
to some pretty heroic comic book
characters Gwen Stacy is well known for
being Peter Parker's tragic girlfriend
and more recently as the web slinging
spider Gwen and Dick Grayson was the
real name of Batman's sidekick Robin who
eventually became Nightwing Gwen's role
in Sky High can be interpreted as a
hybrid of these two characters Robin the
original sidekick has often been the
butt of cultural jokes Gwen's Vengeance
and villainy take root in the fact that
she is unappreciated and misunderstood
in a similar way on the flip side Gwen
Stacy began as the ultimate dream girl
for Spider-Man fans to idealize but both
she and Sky High's Gwen Grayson are more
than they seem the cast of Sky High is
chock full of comedy and sci-fi Stars
but one of the most recognizable cameos
is also uniquely invisible to most kids
Tom Kenny the voice of SpongeBob
SquarePants and Jill tally the voice of
Karen Plankton's computerized wife from
the iconic Nickelodeon cartoon the
actors who are married in real life
appear briefly as Mr and Mrs Timmerman
kids won't tie the couple to their
animated characters but adults are a lot
likelier to recognize the familiar voice
actors after the timmermans purchase a
home from the strongholds early in the
movie they move in and comment
all unpacked and the movers didn't break
a thing I told you we didn't need that
extra insurance oh of course little do
they know that they're moments away from
a floating School falling out of the sky
and smashing their house to Smithereens
fortunately will and his friends save
their new home just in the nick of time
if you look closely the costumes in Sky
High play a subtle role in both
foreshadowing future events and
misleading the audience for example
lashes stretchy sleeves are reminiscent
of a striped prison uniform perhaps
foreshadowing his eventual reveal as a
villainous character then there's Gwen
Grayson's pink color scheme the
traditionally feminine color stands in
stark contrast to the fact that her
super villain Persona royal pain is
always assumed to be male it's also an
interesting color Choice considering
that Gwen's former identity Sue Tenney
blended into the background as a geek
her superpowers were poorly understood
at the time resulting in alienation from
her classmates a bold color like bright
pink isn't one you'd likely associate
with a super villain or a mild-mannered
Wallflower which makes her reveal as
Gwen and her ultimate plan all the more
surprising the soundtrack of Sky High is
full of hits only adults will recognize
Tears for Fears 1985 classic Everybody
wants to rule the world starts the film
off strong other hits include can't stop
the world released by The Go-Go's in
1981 The Smith's 1984 song please please
please let me get what I want and just
what I needed by The Cars which came out
in 1978. this soundtrack represents the
many cues Sky High takes from 80s media
fans of The Breakfast Club which came
out in 1985 will recognize the familiar
archetypes recalled by Sky High's
characters Warren mirrors the brooding
bad boy John Bender magenta calls back
to the withdrawn Allison Reynolds Zach
the goofy geek reflects the character of
Brian Johnson Claire Standish is the
principled Layla and will is
characterized by the same defining
athleticism as Andrew Clark
just before everything goes sideways Mr
boy the hero support teacher has the
following exchange with Layla at the
refreshment table of the homecoming
dance
hey there Layla
you look like you could use a drink no
thanks oh don't worry the bubbles are
just ginger ale he seems to be under the
bizarre impression that Layla would
think he's blithely offering alcohol to
Children Beyond earning a laugh from the
adult audience this moment drives home
that Sky High's Central teenage
characters may be a little more Savvy
and self-aware than the adults around
them whether or not these Dynamics are
actually true in high school is Up For
Debate but grown-up viewers will likely
remember the teenage feeling of thinking
that the adults in their lives were
oblivious to what was really going on
when all American Boy comments on the
importance of avoiding clashing color
schemes between Heroes and Sidekicks
he's taking a light jab at Batman and
Robin's Garb the movie is full of
similar references to its various
Inspirations that only the most Comics
Savvy members of the audience will get
Sky High derives its story from the long
history of superhero comics and the film
is creative enough to craft its own
relationship to the Canon of the medium
loving jokes about tropes are just one
piece of that puzzle Sky High pokes
particular fun at hero and villain
origin stories especially the difference
in experience between those who are
radioactively transformed and those who
inherit powers from their parents
there's even a joke at the end that ties
up the story of Ron Wilson the bus
driver and a charmingly goofy jab at
chemical induced superpowers oh yeah and
Ron Wilson Bus Driver fell into a vat of
toxic waste he now works for the mayor
defending the city from giant robots
toxic waste has been a key element in
the origin stories of iconic characters
ranging from The Joker to the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles so it's only
fitting that Sky High would work in a
nod to this bizarre method of gaining
superpowers Wilson is an unlikely
superhero and that's the point these
super-powered stories are silly and
unrealistic and that's why we love them
after her evil plan is foiled by will
and his friends Gwen grumbles in
detention
I went to puberty twice
for this younger children might hear
this line and ask their parents what's
puberty it sounds bad it may set parents
up for a somewhat awkward conversation
but it will also give them a chuckle
since adults will recall All Too Well
the discomfort and awkwardness of
puberty then again as the movie's last
line States
but hey that's high school
sure puberty sucks but you can also
develop your own sense of style during
it find a group of friends and learn to
balance the desire to belong with the
desire to be true to yourself most
importantly though you learn that there
is no going back to Childhood regardless
of what Sky High says and you're on a
one-way flying bus ride to adulthood but
somehow we all get through it just like
will does kids might not get the humor
of this line but the movie is helping
prepare them for the age at which it'll
eventually click
viewing The Flintstones through adult
eyes reveals a complex world with a lot
of Darker problematic moments you
wouldn't notice them if you're a kid but
if you're a grown-up you yabba dabba doo
while The Flintstones is clearly a riff
on the groundbreaking sitcom The
Honeymooners it does make a few notable
changes The Flintstones is a bit more of
an equal opportunity offender when it
comes to domestic abuse Ralph Kramden
threatened to beat his wife so often
that his verbal promise of violence
became a TV catchphrase
audiences never actually saw Ralph get
physical with his wife but viewers of
The Flintstones saw it work the other
way around Fred often threatened Wilma
but that's where it stopped however when
Fred did something Wilma didn't like
which was often she'd clock him on the
head drop heavy objects on his feet
fling him across the room and who knows
what else
of course Fred wasn't the easiest
caveman to live with he had serious
anger management issues he constantly
Twisted the truth and his views on the
role of women in society really did
belong in the Stone Age how many times
have I told you A Woman's Place is in
the home
for a show that took place millions of
years ago The Flintstones is
surprisingly Progressive about a number
of issues in the 1960s it was
revolutionary that the series was open
about how Barney and Betty Rubble
couldn't naturally conceive a child like
The Flintstones and how upset they were
about it it was a major TV event in
February 1963 when Wilma gave birth to
Pebbles and afterwards the rebels spent
an inordinate amount of time hanging out
with the new arrival They just won a
baby so bad as a last resort they make a
wish on a falling star the next morning
their wish has apparently been granted
and they find a baby boy at their
doorstep a supernaturally strong orphan
named Bambam
oh Barney we've got our very own baby
however the couple still had a long way
to go before they could call Bam Bam
their own adult viewers will certainly
feel some empathy as the rebels jump
through legal Hoops to adopt the little
Powerhouse and are only granted custody
at the last minute the whole ordeal
mentally drains Barney to the point
where he wants to take his own life
goodbye
luckily Fred shows up just in time to
save the day and Bam Bam's new Daddy
The Flintstones wouldn't be The
Flintstones without animals birds and
other creatures performing all kinds of
household and mechanical tasks the
modern Stone Age family seems to have an
animal for every job a mastodon instead
of a shower a monkey bird tag team
inside a record player a swordfish for a
kitchen knife and an artistic bird that
functions as a prehistoric Polaroid
camera just to name a few you have to
wonder what these animals actually think
of Fred a guy's a pig and Neanderthal
you're dead to me can opener it doesn't
seem like the animals on The Flintstones
are getting paid or have any freedom
whatsoever in other words the humans of
The Flintstones have enslaved animals
forcing all creatures great and small
into being beasts of Burden while this
is cruel some animals have it worse than
others birds tails are constantly being
yanked a pelican serves as a trash can
meaning people force-feed it garbage and
possibly worst of all a variety of poor
creatures are forced to sacrifice their
entire lives for construction and Mining
I've had just just about enough for
these lazy [ __ ] using us as slave labor
the uprising is upon us
like most sitcoms of the 1960s The
Flintstones was not serialized each
episode completely stood on its own with
Fred Wilma Barney and Betty getting into
some kind of hairy situation and
resolving it by the end of the episode
kids can accept this they can enjoy
shows on a surface level adults may want
to know more about developments in The
Flintstones Universe such as what
happens after the events in the episode
Dino and Juliet in this Comic version of
Romeo and Juliet Fred Flintstone and a
new neighbor get into a heated dispute
instead of the warring factions teenage
Offspring falling in love their pet
dinosaurs do Dino Falls instantly head
over heels for Juliet the cute new
sauropod in town
if that don't beat the bush dinos in
love as lovers are want to do Dino and
Juliet steal away for some privacy which
results in the birth of more than a
dozen babies never again on The
Flintstones or Juliet or her children
with Dino scene apparently he's an
absentee father and they'll love him and
leave him time
after a few years on the air sitcoms
tend to bring in a new character to
breathe fresh life into the series
homeless teen Luke showed up on Growing
Pains cousin Oliver appeared on The
Brady Bunch and The Simpsons mocked the
entire concept with a random character
named Roy adding a new character is
often a desperate attempt to boost low
ratings yeah yeah how's it hanging
everybody morning Roy The Flintstones
pioneered this move back in 1965 with
the arrival of a tiny smug Alien named
The Great Gazoo the little green E.T had
been sent through space and time to
prehistoric Earth as punishment for
making a doomsday device on his home
planet kazoo has clearly seen his share
of Dark Places
get off me you big llama guess who where
have you been Fred and Barney discover
him and rather than report him to the
government they befriend him although
Gazoo mainly seems to call them dum-dums
and magically disappear whenever Fred is
talking to him which gives the
impression that Fred has mental issues
or maybe The Great Gazoo isn't real at
all and Fred and Barney have been
ingesting some unknown substances with
mysterious side effects
yes The Flintstones is a cartoon and it
passed strict Network standards in the
conservative early 1960s but somehow it
managed to sneak in the occasional dirty
joke for the adults in the room in one
episode Fred and Barney are watching TV
when they lose reception Fred asks if
everything is in working order and
Barney immediately hits Fred with a
comeback that would make most parents
blush in front of their kids how's your
antenna fine Fred how's yours it would
also seem they had adult films way back
in the Stone Age while Fred's getting a
checkup a doctor holds up Fred's x-ray
prompting Flintstone to joke how about a
doc Flintstone in an x-rated picture
while these man cave jokes were right up
Fred and Barney's alley we can't help
but wonder how Wilma and Betty would
react
burn
[Music]